[Musique]
et pour débuter Nicolas le procès de
l'attentat du SuperU de trp s'est ouvert
ce jeudi ce lundi pardon il avait
notamment coûté la vie à Arnaud Beltram
un lieutenant colonel de gendarmerie des
ivelines il a officier justement dans le
département effectivement Grégory SEP
personnes comparaissent devant la Cour
d'Assise spéciale de Paris jusqu'au 23
février CIN prévenus au total seront
jugés pour association de malfaiteurs
terroristes criminels et deux autres
pour des délits NEX les faits on va les
rappeler hein le 23 mars 2018 un
attentat terroriste av visé
l'hypermarché SuperU de treèb faisant
quatre victimes dont le lieutenant
colonel Arnaud Bertram Beltram pardon
l'océan officier des Yvelines avait pris
la place d' notage dans le magasin visé
par l'attaque Arnaud Beltram avait passé
une partie de sa carrière dans les
ivelines notamment au sein du groupement
blindé de gendarmerie mobile de
Versailles satori aujourd'hui une rue
porte son nom dans le quartier des
chantiers après la neige ça c'était la
semaine dernière c'est maintenant le
vent qui a semé la pagaille dans les
transports en commun oui grégoryi des
vents violents ont provoqué les chutes
d'arbres sur les voies résultat le
trafic du rerc entre Versailles chantier
et Massi palzo a été fortement fortement
perturbé il a même été à l'arrêt pendant
plusieurs heures la faute à la tempête
Isa qui a balayé la France cette nuit le
département des ivelines était placé en
vigilance jaune pour vent violent le
trafic lui est revenu à la normale dans
le courant de la matinée en 2026 les
habitants de porscheville et de Limet
pourront regarder la télévision on
espère TV 78 grâce à deux nouveaux
panneaux solaires voilà 18000 au total
c'est le nombre de panneaux solaires qui
seront installés sur une dizaine
d'hectares du site EDF basé à
porscheville une convention vient d'être
signée entre la Région Île-de-France et
EDF pour transformer l'édifice en ferme
photovoltaïque ces panneaux vont
alimenter en électricité les communes de
Limet et Porcheville et vous l'avez dit
ils produiront 10 MW soit l'équivalent
de la consommation annuelle de près de
6400 foyers les travaux devraient
débuter à la fin de l'année 2025 pour
une mise en service l'année suivante une
vigilance à présent depuis le début de
l'année une nouvelle arnaque sévi en
Île-de-France notamment dans les
ivelines attention aux imposteurs
Grégory depuis le début de l'année les
brigades de gendarmerie d'Île-de-France
constatent une recrue d'essence des vols
à la fausse qualité autrement dit des
délinquants se font passer pour des faux
policiers ou des faux gendarmes vêtus de
brassard et parfois d'une fausse carte
professionnelle ces délincants font
croire et bien aux habitants qu'une
série de cambriolages touchent leur
quartier et qu'ils doivent faire ben le
tour de leurs habitations profitant et
ben parfois de la naïveté des habitants
pour et bien voler ou dérober et
préparer peut-être de cambriolage alors
il a il y a quelques conseils justement
pour lutter contre ces ces cambriolages
effectivement d'abord de ne jamais
laisser une personne inconnue seule dans
une pièce de votre habitation et puis le
deuxième conseil qu'on peut vous donner
c'est de contacter les forces de l'ordre
pour vérifier auprès de l'administration
concernée la présence d'un de ses agents
sur le terrain et on finit avec cette
information la SPA a publié son bilan de
l'année dernière 2023 il y a du bon et
du moins bon moins d'abandon moins
d'adoption voilà le bilan et le premier
constat qu'on peut faire du bilan 2023
de laasa en terme de chiffre 9565
animaux ont été pris en charge en
Île-de-France par les six refruges de la
SPA basé dans les Yvelines alors on
retrouve Hermeray Orgeval et Plaisir
dans les Yvelines c'est 2 % de moins
qu'en 2022 néanmoins l'association des
nombres 8643 adoptions soit 7 % de moin
qu'en 2022 un chiffre qui explique
pourquoi les refuges restent saturés
merci Nicolas et comme d'habitude si
vous aussi près de chez vous vous voyez
une actualité qui vous fait réagir dans
les Evelin n'hésitez pas à la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news